all right uh let me bring in kareem
um my boy kareem we did a uh cast
prior in the summer i think in the
spring on your podcast
uh yeah how you doing my friend
i'm great i'm great i've been a long
time how you doing rich good man so
what's the word what do you think about
all this stuff like you know can we save
the west or just let it burn
uh i have like uh i have a bigger
perspective than than these details that
there was they were talking about there
there is a great book actually a great
great book really i really recommend it
it's called the death of the west by
patrick j uh uh pacanon
okay it is talking about like a million
variable that
that
because of it the west will fall the
west will will die and he wrote it in
and the number was very modest comparing
to now like the number of divorce
abortion like a lot of things was there
any solutions in the book to the problem
no it's it's he's saying and and by the
way
you're screwed
yeah yeah he's saying it's inevitable it
is inevitable so from a bigger
perspective
you have like you have you have a big
problem which is like democracy i'm
sorry to say that it's very shocking
because like why do i let like a bunch
of idiots make
make like a great decision for me no
so
there is there is two type of solution
and both is
unapplicable
why because the first one you need the
enlightenment dictator like an alpha
like a well-knowledged alpha with bunch
of uh well-knowledged guys which nobody
seems to like anymore today like any
time you have an alpha male like a like
a white straight
like
alpha male that like has that imposing
sort of figure they they just grind the
guy down man they just hate guys like
that now
exactly so this will get like a radical
changes toward the positivity and that
will never happen in the west that's
okay that's for voting patterns you know
specifically when i'm talking about that
like women will do different things
behind closed doors you know just just
so i'm clear on that
yeah so the second the second option is
to change it by democracy so you need to
change the collective awareness of the
whole population and that will take one
to two generation 25 to 50 years to
change the collective awareness of the
whole population that's almost
impossible
that's right there it it goes back to my
first exhibit is when we start seeing
people vote for policies that support
what exactly it is that you're defining
there that's when you're going to see a
turnaround but until then when you you
know when you watch what's happening
this is what you're getting let me ask
you this question because um you're in
the middle east
and um
you know like as an outside observer
like you're watching what's happening in
western countries
um how are things in the middle east for
you as a man like you know do you see
you see an ascent you see a decline like
where do you see things like is it
growing or is it dying
uh
on uh demographical level no we are
growing like right we are we're above
2.5 like three three point two three
point five right
depend yeah rate replacement rate so so
nothing nothing to be compared with with
canada and the western democratic
country right so in demographic level
but we are we are now fighting the like
the value exported from the west toward
us
and it's very difficult to find you're
dealing with the wokeness is what you're
saying
yes exactly so
i mean
as far as immigration goes because there
is a lot of immigration coming to canada
from
around the world a good chunk of it
comes from the middle east it's not
fixing anything but you're seeing that
wokeness is being imported to the middle
east as well too
exactly i'm starting to see it on um
apps like uh tiktok actually because
because i because i update usually about
two to three times a week you know with
shorts on a tick tock and they have this
home page and you scroll through it and
today i saw a middle eastern woman with
tattoos on her face showing a good part
of her body
behaving very westernly
yes but the rest of uh conservative
which is the biggest layer of the
society you will never see her and or
hear about her
so you you're checking like
the sliver
liberal
layer of the society
wasn't him in that book again
it is it is called the death of the west
okay by patrick j pacquiaon
the death of the west it have like like
a lot of indicators and variables that
will make the worst fall anyway so to
change it as as as one man uh that's in
your dream you can you cannot you cannot
do it but
let me say this you can't change
anything else without fixing your own
problems so you have to start by
yourself even if you was thinking about
the rest that's it
thanks brother yeah all right see you
man
most welcome take care
you